todo el trabajo que hemos hecho hasta
ahora con integrales de línea ha sido
únicamente con funciones escalares esto
lo que quiere decir es que teníamos una
cierta función f que dependía de xy si
dos números y al evaluar la función
obteníamos una vez más su número es
decir un escalar no aparecían vectores
por ningún lado lo que quiero hacer en
este vídeo es agarrar un poco de
práctica con vectores para que después
podamos entender qué quiere decir hacer
una integral de línea de una función con
valores vectoriales para entonces vamos
a empezar viendo algunos ejemplos de
funciones vectoriales y sabes que la
mejor forma de empezar esto es dibujando
una curva entonces déjame mover este fx
y por otro lado y vamos a tomar una
curva se va esta curva está
parametrizado como siempre así de la
forma estándar ya sabes una x una y
etcétera es decir tenemos x es igual a x
dt y además tenemos y es igual a 7
tenemos que decir donde se mueve
supongamos que se mueve entre a y b
entonces pongámosle por aquí que a es
menor o igual que t
y esto es menor o igual que ve sale
entonces déjame hacer un dibujo para qué
pues nos quede un poco más clara la
explicación aquí voy a poner un eje por
aquí voy a poner otro eje como sus
flechitas el eje x el eje y vamos a
dibujar la curva arbitrariamente
supongamos que empieza por aquí es decir
que entre igualada empieza aquí la curva
empieza a recorrer el plano xy digamos
así y llega a este punto de acá
en este punto final corresponde a ti
igual a b sus coordenadas verdad sus
coordenadas tienen que ver con x debe
eso de ahí sería la coordenada x viene
de aquí arriba y eso de ahí es la
coordenada en aquí es para cuando te es
igual a a y sus coordenadas en r2 o sea
en el plano x serían x de a
qué es esto de aquí y qué es la altura y
que queda pues más o menos por aquí
ahora eso de ahí ya lo habíamos visto
antes esto ya que es la forma estándar
de describir una curva utilizando dos
ecuaciones paramétricas pero lo que
quiero hacer ahora es describir esta
misma curva pero con vectores es decir
voy a usar una función vectorial vamos a
ponerle un cierto nombre así que suena
como a vectores le voy a poner por aquí
pues digamos que tenemos una función que
se llama r aquí arriba le voy a poner
una flechita para indicar que es
vectorial en los libros a veces lo
puedes ver como en negrita c pero en el
pizarrón o aquí es difícil después
ponerlo en negrita entonces le voy a
poner una flecha de vector y supongamos
que es una función que depende de t
entonces esto de aquí van a ser vectores
de posición de jal escribo por aquí
vectores de posición estoy especificando
esto porque en general cuando alguien
habla de digamos este vector y este otro
vector esos vectores son iguales siempre
y cuando tengan la misma dirección y la
misma magnitud no importa mucho donde
hayan empezado y donde hayan terminado
entonces si la dirección y la longitud
coinciden son el mismo pero los vectores
de posición todos están anclados en el
origen es decir todos empiezan en el 0 0
cuando hablamos de vectores de posición
estamos especificando exactamente un
vector
estamos especificando un vector pues ya
se en dos dimensiones o en tres
dimensiones o donde sea pero que está
anclado en el origen literalmente
estamos tomando una flechita que va del
0 0 hacia allá digamos entonces vamos a
ver si podemos describir esta curva en
términos de ciertos vectores de posición
vale como le vamos a hacer para hacer
esto pues fíjate déjame cambiar al rosa
bueno no el verde el verde está bien
entonces esto es igual a equis dt por el
vector unitario y es decir el vector
unitario horizontal ese de ahí es el
vector 10 fíjate como la y tiene un
gorrito en vez de un punto más 7 x jota
otra vez tiene su gorrito jota ahora es
el vector unitario en posición vertical
en tres dimensiones tendríamos que sumar
otro término pero aquí sólo estamos en
dos dimensiones
entonces la forma en la cual estos
funciones que para cualquier t a déjame
ponerle por aquí que es menor o igual
que t y es menor o igual que b entonces
para cualquier t en este intervalo
obtenemos exactamente lo mismo que a la
izquierda sólo que ahora vamos a tener
vectores déjame hacer otro plano para
dejar esto muy bien muy bien explicado
ahí tenemos el eje y aquí tenemos el eje
x entonces cuando evaluamos rda eso ahí
es nuestro punto inicial entonces déjame
hacer esto
rd y lo voy a hacer por aquí a la
izquierda r o sea nuestra función de los
vectores de posición en a va a ser igual
a equis de x y el vector unitario en la
dirección de x más allá de a por el
vector unitario en la dirección vertical
o bien en la dirección y cómo se vería
esto
bueno pues xd xd a es esta longitud
entonces es x de a por el vector
unitario supongamos que el vector
unitario que da pues por aquí entonces
lo que hacemos es multiplicar eso por x
de a es decir estamos alargando s
y lo mismo es para idea va entonces en
que acabamos con todo esto lo que
estamos haciendo es hacer una
combinación de iu y j multiplicados por
ciertos escalares entonces lo que vamos
a obtener es un vector que se va a ver
más o menos de este estilo es una
flechita que empieza aquí en el 0 que
está anclado en el origen y que apunta a
un cierto punto que de hecho eso de aquí
es déjame le pongo aquí esto de aquí es
rda y entonces qué sucede con rda pues
bueno rda justamente apunta al extremo
inicial de nuestra curva pero ahora
vamos a movernos un poquito vamos a
considerar digamos rd
vamos a moverlo bush h
entonces eso de ahí es igual a equis de
a más h multiplicado por el vector
unitario y más llegue a más h
multiplicado por el vector unitario jota
ahora cómo se va a ver esto bueno lo que
estamos haciendo es movernos un poquito
sobre la curva es decir vamos a tener x
de a más a che y llegue a más h digamos
algo así entonces ahora vamos a obtener
un nuevo vector unitario no no persona
un nuevo vector de posición que queda
más o menos por aquí es decir es un
punto que todavía está sobre la curva
déjame hacerlo con el mismo color que la
expresión o sea en amarillo y va a
quedar una flecha de este estilo este de
aquí sería r de a más h sale entonces
conforme seguimos incrementando el valor
de t hasta que llegamos a b estos
vectores de posición van a seguir
apuntando a puntos que están sobre la
curva entonces la curva cómo va a quedar
lo voy a poner con otro color la curva
va a ser otra vez como una
se iba a definir exactamente la misma
curva que en el plano de arriba a la
izquierda por ejemplo r de bbva para
caber daba al extremo final entonces
ahora tenemos un vector hoy queda más o
menos derechito entonces este vector de
ahí es r
db sale y vale entonces con un poco de
suerte espero que te hayas dado cuenta
que estos vectores de posición están
apuntando justo a los puntos de la curva
entonces es exactamente lo mismo en
cierto sentido solo que arriba son
puntos y aquí abajo son vectores bueno
le vamos a dejar aquí en el próximo
vídeo veremos cómo derivar una función
vectorial hasta pronto